in 2015 being the year of sequels I
bring you a review for the sequel that's
just probably right under a Hotel
Transylvania 2 right about there Hot Tub
Time Machine 2 so the trailer for Hot
Tub Time Machine 2 showed us that they
keep going to the Hot Tub Time Machine
it shows them in the Revolutionary War
it shows them becoming the Beatles it
shows them becoming all these pop
culture icons you like that might be
hilarious I'm here to tell you no no
it's not hilarious when it's in the
movie it's actually hilarious I'm here
to tell you that's just not what the
movie is this movie is just a huge bait
and switch in Hot Tub Time Machine 2 it
picks up where everyone left off last
times like everyone's rich and
successful and then someone shoots two
really obnoxious guy in the dead so they
have to go through the Hot Tub Time
Machine to stop that from happening
what it is and of going in with ten
years into the future let me have this
mess there's something sincere about the
first movie you know it's like they go
back to their youth you get to know they
get to do it again they get to start
over this one's some sloppy ass kind of
murder mystery you can gravitate towards
the concept of getting a do-over a
mulligan in life and you have the
eighties references to keep you company
and you just start laughing in the first
Hot Tub Time Machine if you dug the
movie I mean there were some chuckle
worthy scenes in the movie I'm not gonna
say I didn't at least chuckle but
nothing really made me laugh oh wait
something did the end credits of this
movie made me laugh and that's where the
trailer comes in the trailer where
they're becoming these pop culture icons
that's all in the end credits that's
right the movie wraps up and one of the
dudes from you know the Hot Tub Time
Machine crew comes back through the time
machine he's dressed in Revolutionary
War attire and he's like we gotta go
help America happen you're like oh my
gosh it's like winning him back to the
feature with Doc's like roads where
we're going we don't need roads and
you're like next movie's gonna be sweet
and I'd like to be the first to say that
that guy right there he's not actually
saying that Hot Tub Time Machine him
back to the feature are on the same
levels not saying that at all it's just
giving you an illustration of comparison
of a movie that sets up the sequel so
there you go alright that's what I was
thinking about in this movie and then it
was all the end credits
yeah and credits shows all that and
then some and everything you saw in the
trailer is like the filmmakers of this
movie were like alright well I know the
script cuz I read the script I've made
the movie I don't think it's gonna get a
third one so everything that we set up
to be the third but we're just gonna
show in the end credits
least we get to show it turned out to be
the funniest part in the movie guys I'm
not going to take up much
more your time you just gonna say Hot
Tub Time Machine 2 had a couple of
chuckle worthy parts that had Patel you
have a Hot Tub Time Machine everything's
right at your fingertips men used to
have all the possibilities right there
but the movie was a mess it was sloppy
the jokes weren't that funny you would
think from the time it took from the
first movie to the second movie to come
out they could have hashed out the
writing written some really solid script
it's just not how it went down watch the
end credits it's not worth the $10 of
admission but watch the end credits it's
pretty funny I will say Hot Tub Time
Machine - you're not gonna remember it
in t minus ten minutes yep or you forgot
or if I already forgot did I always
remember so your favorite time travel
movie or a movie involving a multiverse
in general to kind of go hand in hand
these days so you kind of got a mesh
them together in the question whatever
your favorite is comment below let me
know and as always if you liked what
you've seen here and you want to see
more click right here to see more
[Music]